love this man like a brother love
working with him on NFL Network and he
will be part of NFL gameday morning
starting at 9:00 a.m. Eastern Time and
he'll be with us until he leaves us to
go do the radio for Westwood one good to
see Kurt Warner hall-of-famer how they
starting to pick up yes somebody get
excited you feel it right that's all
right it's just it's such a great week
of the year for us you know I mean again
I'm all football all the time I know you
got stuff all year long but this is my
king this is it for me and I love this
week seeing all the people come out but
just the anticipation of the big game
because I remember it like it was
yesterday well I mean you you had three
big games of your career and you had the
most prolific passing games in the
history of the game 1 2 & 3 until Brady
went to work in recent days but when you
think Super Bowl week what's the memory
like boom your weekend memory the memory
is throwing the touchdown pass to win
the Super Bowl because that's just how
you do it right from the time I was this
big
I would watch every Super Bowl and then
I would go out in my front yard and
whatever quarterback won the Super Bowl
that's who I was in my front yard and we
would play out the whole Super Bowl
again and I would always throw the
game-winning touchdown pass so to have
my first one play out like that and to
throw that pass at the end that's always
the first memory but it's so much more
than there's so much more that goes into
it
just remember the teams and remember the
guys and remember what it takes to get
to this point I mean that's what's so
great about it is every time I step on
the Super Bowl field when we do our show
I think man just one more can I could I
have one more game in this moment
because it was just it's so awesome as a
football I mean and making the moment
the moment you are a personification of
that and what it can mean for a life a
career and it's tough for me to think
that this isn't the Holmes's moment that
this is this is the one right here your
two he's he's got him here and and he's
just gonna meet this moment and I'm
that's why I'm leaning Chiefs right now
I'm wondering what you think of that
whole idea I mean here's the beautiful
thing is that we've seen that scenario
play out many times right the guy that
everybody's talking about you know the
main man for one of the teams comes in
to the Super Bowl and he shines in this
moment walks away with the MVP and it
happens but we've also seen the other
side of it like the guy that nobody
expected right you know the guy that you
know we weren't even talking about all
week comes in and has his moment in the
Super Bowl as well and so would I be
surprised at Patrick Mahone came out of
this game and had the MVP not know but I
look at the other side and I look at a
guy like Raheem most hurt and I say to
myself that was me 20 years ago right
that cut by seven teams has this moment
to help his team get here and then that
would be a beautiful story too is that
on the biggest stage in the biggest
moment the guy that was told seven times
you're not good enough you can't be here
you're never gonna make it pass his
shining moment too so I just that's what
I love about it is you don't know what
the story is going to be written on
Super Bowl Sunday and I could see so
many things play out and that's what
excites me is it will it be you know the
guy that catapults himself into the next
great quarterback or will it be some
unknown guy that wins the MVP and you
know puts his that state makes a stamp
in history in this biggest game in the
biggest game of his career Kurt Warner
the poll question Chris and then we'll
just close it out for the day here on
the Rich Eisen show what do you got all
right Kurt we're looking at x-factors
who do you think might be the biggest
one on Super Sunday
Deebo Samuel Kendrick born Damian
Williams Michael Hardman those your four
choices Nikko Harlan who was the third
one if Damian Williams
because you know they're gonna screen
game there in at least attempt to screen
game their way down the field
potentially if that I know rush really
goes at it I got to pick one of those
guys huh yes you can after yeah answer
the question first um I'm gonna say
McCall Hardman I just think at some
point you know the San Francisco is
gonna play this game like we're not
gonna give up the big play we're not
gonna give up the big play we're not
gonna give up the big play and everybody
thinks if they give up one it's gonna be
Tyreke hill right right but I just feel
that it's gonna be a young kid in this
moment the other speed guy that they
forget about Kelsey and he'll we got to
take them out a guy like that to just
somehow someway gets the ball in his
hands and bang he's gone and he makes
that big play so then who's yours if you
can go off the board if you will
I'm gonna go Kyle use check can I do
that you may is that and the funny thing
is I don't know if it's gonna be a big
pass play for a touchdown or it's even
gonna be with the ball in his hands but
they asked that guy to do so much and
now that he's healthy
like I think back to the greatest show
on turf and we had all these weapons on
the outside that it was tough to cover
right I believe George kiddo and Kyle
you check are kind of like Kyle
Shanahan's you know guys pawn pieces
that are different than everybody else
you're gonna see him do some things
whether it's set a block lead you know
catch a screen you know lead a big run
where I think he's gonna have a huge
factor and we may never even call his
name for carrying the ball one single
time or he could wheel route it right
when he's actually expected I mean it's
no sadly possible Kurt Warner here on
the Rich Eisen show story line this week
that I'm not here for is that the fact
that Jimmy Garoppolo had just six pass
attempts after throwing the interception
against Minnesota and only eight in the
NFC Championship game is a sign that the
Niners don't trust him and that if
that's in that if the games on his
shoulders they lose I wonder what you
think of that yeah I don't buy that
you're hearing it though I hear and you
know and it makes sense but what I think
it was is simply just hey we got a young
quarterback that's never been here
before
okay you made a mistake not that we're
worried and scared oh my gosh you made a
mistake let's not put the ball in his
hands but it simply just made a mistake
settle them back down and let's hand the
football off because we can do that and
we can you can we can win that way and
then from that point they haven't really
had to throw it you know at any point in
time a I sat down with Jimmy earlier in
the week and I was asking him like okay
outside of winning what does this game
look like for Jimmy Garoppolo yeah
what's the perfect scenario and of
course he was trying to be politically
correct and like hey just win baby if I
have to throw eight passes and I'm
thinking there is no way Jimmy Garoppolo
wants to just throw eight passes to win
this Super Bowl and I don't think
they're going to I think they have full
trust in him we saw it numerous times
this year where the third we gotta put
it in his hands and you gotta win it
Arizona you mentioned it New Orleans we
saw it so I believe they have full
confidence in in Jimmy Garoppolo if
Kansas City goes into this game thinking
Jimmy Garoppolo cannot win this game for
the Niners with his weapons and the way
he's played all year I think that would
be the biggest mistake they could make
Kurt Warner here on the Rich Eisen show
in the few minutes that we have left are
you with us for all seven and a half
hours on NFL Network or do you tap out
and you got to go get your radio booth
ready okay are you believe I may have to
tap out and miss just a half an hour or
so at the end just a half an hour me
just half an hour no what I'm gonna do
sirs get right and nervous like I can
just go up let's call the game I'm all
good they're an hour and a half before
up in the radio booth it's like what for
what just as long as I get there before
kickoff I should be good so we'll have
that conversation I want to be with you
guys for the vote we're only seven and a
half hours this year that's it oh I
thought we were always 89 hours I got
salad it will be eight and a half hours
long but we're done after seven and a
half I got you I think I succumb I
should be able to give you seven and a
half you can touch the top it's gonna
take to get up to the radio booth really
seriously right I'm gonna walk up let's
make that happen and make that happen
nine minutes I have a feeling it weird
it will be a wonderful moment where we
have a half an hour to go you're like
guys I gotta go
like four flights up so there you go I
could run the stairs and get up there
that badge right man all right it's game
prediction time presented by DIRECTV 4k
a quick reminder that the big game on
Sunday is brought to you in 4k HDR by
DIRECTV kurz Kansas City or San
Francisco who do you have whoo all right
here you say on Sunday yeah you got it
hear me say it on Sunday because I
always reserve the right to change my
Pig or at least nothing else to make
everybody tune in to NFL gameday morning
very go on Sunday to get it yeah but
here's the thing
I believe this is kind of in my mind the
best team in the NFL against the best
player in the NFL and you sit back and
you go ok so who wins the Super Bowl the
best team or the best player that
dynamic player I believe quarterbacks
can help you get to the Super Bowl and
can be that part of it I believe teams
win championships so as of right now I
am leaning towards the San Francisco
49ers to win this one in a close one
over Patrick mahomes and the Chiefs
that's why there is no I and Curt or
Warner pretty much right there pretty
much so you're about the top team baby
about the team yeah I don't know man
mahomes I just keep on thinking he is
the ultimate x-factor right that it he's
the ultimate well he erases anything if
there's clock management issues that
Andy Reid's been having problems with
420 hoods for two decades and they're
gone if they make a mistake and say you
know blowing up not seeing a clear fake
punt coming Damian Williams runs out of
bounds to give an extra timeout back to
Tennessee
mahomes will just make the play and just
erase all the problems it isn't that
what makes it perfect for us as analysts
so for me calling the game that no
matter what happens early in this game
no one is ever gonna shut this TV off
right nobody is gonna tune out because
they're always gonna say oh that guy on
the other side yeah nothing is too big
nothing is impossible when you have the
ball in that guy's hands and that's a
beautiful thing for us as we get ready
to call again you no doubt about it
it's oh it's you and Harlan right for
Westwood exactly alright and then me
you ah've & mooch to start and then we
got a cast of carefully fond Millers
going to join us okay I've heard that
rumor and then so we've got the meeting
coming up tomorrow you'll be there for
the entire meeting right well I'm gonna
tap out because I don't even need to
worry about the last half hour at least
go get some food or some water
Warner on Twitter and on Instagram love
you man thanks for coming buddy Joe for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app